we'll divide you guys up into segments
we'll get five suggestions
then we'll drop a beat and have some fun
so uh this this triangular wedge over
here what would you like to
wrap up someone just went whoo we got
picked first
daniel speech at the oscars daniel
killer's speech of the oscars now i i
didn't watch this because i watched um i
watched the film he won it for judas and
the black messiah uh what was his speech
about
at the end of it he was like my parents
they had sex it was incredible
what if you didn't hear that apparently
daniel kahlua ended his
speech by saying my parents had sex it
was incredible
no one else seems to agree with you on
that one but okay
i think a lot of people were just
annoyed that he wanted to like wait this
prick's not [ __ ] american yeah more
british people coming over and taking
your jobs okay so daniel kahlua's
oscar accepted a speech where he
referenced his parents
making love um let's come to back of the
room back in or come to you because you
guys always get left out what do you
want to hear rap
midwest about lenin in the midwest cool
cool vladimir lenin obviously the leader
of the soviet uprising and the
revolution through the bolsheviks but in
the midwest the midwest is like
kansas and [ __ ] where's that someone
said yeah it's kansas cool
i drove through there every time i
stopped to get gas and paid
people were like you sound like you're
from bridger it was lovely
i just went i am stroll away okay so
daniel kahlua's speech
vladimir lenin if he was in the midwest
let's come to
uh the this this part of the room but on
this side what's your wrapper
those are two pretty good suggestions uh
so i'm aware if it feels nerve-wracking
don't worry it doesn't matter if it's uh
adverse events associated with
antidepressants
adverse events associated with
antidepressants yeah
cool that's that's real great this is
some real discussion down here being
like this is actually really hard
they're being
i was excited for this rap and now
they're just being cruel
okay middle of the room this side when
you wake up in the middle of night and
your catch is vomited on your floor
when you wake up in the middle of the
night and your cats just vomited on your
floor
is this an ongoing thing or a one-off
event uh
i want a cat but that's why we don't
have oh you want a cat but that's why
you don't have one
okay cool well not all cats do that so
you know maybe take a chance
[ __ ] buy one don't get a second-hand
cat basically if you want that
um a secondhand cat a rescue cat it's
like
like recycled toilet paper in it like
it's the good thing to do but
scratchy so
[Music]
a real old joke of mine about very proud
of it and what do you guys
oh [ __ ] there's people in this little
wedding here hello there um what would
you guys all like a rough about
saddam hussein scared to break up with
his college girlfriend
i didn't know this gig was only attended
by the [ __ ] soliloquizing
intellectuals of manhattan
they were like we can only make
suggestion if it is multi-syllabic
so we didn't hear that saddam hussein
scared to break up with his girlfriend
the uh adverse effects associated with
antidepressants a cat that wakes you up
by throwing up on the floor daniel
killer's oscar at 7 speech which i
thought would be the weirdest [ __ ]
one but apparently
not and vladimir lenin if you live in
the midwest now yeah that's
that's that okay well the thing is i'm
definitely going to forget some or all
of those suggestions but we'll try our
best
i got my dj at the back dj if you're
able to drop that beat good sir let's
have some bloody fun
ah okay i'm glad you're getting some
energy you seem pretty excited for this
this is good uh and which one to begin
with
we got it from the back i think we'll
start with air move forward this sounds
this sounds good cool
quiet voice at the back but i pay you
attention transplants from russia
vladimir lenin that's before stalin
and before putin off to the winter
palace and shooting
all the czars stabbing them right
through the brass they were wearing
little diamonds so they had to finish
them off with the bayonet but he's got
to move but he's not here yet on an
airplane
learning with the mustache he's up there
like yes you know i must test
what can i do when i get dropped off
maybe visit
ihop get a little pancake wander in
hello my name's vladimir look at my chin
very pointy
i would assume when i died not in the
red square not in the tomb now i'm in a
little graveyard in kansas
all the russians come over they line up
like oh vladimir you're the hero of
communisties like i know i'm dearly
missed
now let me talk about a parental tryst
otherwise daniel k
wouldn't exist he was there on stage
with his statuette
saying so my mum and dad get pretty
horny
at the best of times i know i shouldn't
say this but i really don't mind
died on the bed he was like give a twirl
mum on top like reverse cowgirl
semen egg those all mixed and now daniel
look what you pick you're a real gong
winner getting all of the statues moving
on over here i'm glad i asked you gold
you say
i really won't spoil it said adam
hussein had the gold on his toilet
walked to his palace in baghdad i would
agree with you all that he's a mad lad
still very scared by the ladies he was
like oh no that [ __ ] crazy i know that
was a russian accent but i won't do
iraqi
why cause i'll get blogged about end
badly here's to damn with a mustache too
why do the dictators just look like two
of each other cause he looked like
stalin as well
meets with his girl and he's like oh
hell uh i'm really going to be in
trouble
so what does he do asks his body double
to do that for him cause he had plenty
he's like
oh girl you're mental you she she picks
up the fork she picks up the knife
she says saddam you said i was the love
of your life and he stabs him
in the chest then she walks out there
sit down's bereft he's like oh
she likes murdering too and that's what
i like to do
bring all of my citizens and subjects
pain bombayage
saddam hussein and let me exchange this
asking you all a question
cheer if you're on antidepressants wow
that's the whole room many bad events i
really would assume you'd be like oh
chris the rats not rehearsed talk about
the effects that are adverse that means
negative
opposite a positive i go to the medicals
and i get inquisitive like what will it
do
how will it function will it give me
erectile dysfunction they say chris
so you gotta pop a pill that the comedy
gig takes to the
nil go to the loo go to the bogs knock
it back
yeah it'll do the job you gotta time it
like 45 minutes
you're watching the rap like when will
this finish still don't know i could
prolong it
penis growing out really schlong it
other things that you'll find that it's
trouble to sleep your musculature starts
to stagger it's feeling so weak we did
sit down
any other things what was the last
remind me now
[Music]
oh [ __ ] ah seeing that sick i wake up
i'm like whoa
what's that i can sniff and i look there
i see a lot of little stick coming
outside
of the little box i gotta pick it up i
take a bit of bounty i say
bad little kitty you should see these
you should throw up in the grass outside
think of all the little sardines that
provide while you're waking me up the
smell is appalling
but a cat just does that it's called
hairballing here we go